looking for a breakthrough on brexit
forest Johnson was in Ireland making
last-minute appeals to his Irish
counterpart over the backstop the
insurance policy to avoid a hard border
between Ireland and Northern Ireland
after brexit for a man who last week had
Britain on course for a No Deal brexit
his message was more diplomatic I want
to get a deal like you I've looked
carefully at No Deal I've assessed its
consequences both our country and yes of
course we could do it the UK could
certainly get through it but be in no
doubt that outcome would be a failure of
statecraft for which we would all be
responsible meanwhile in Westminster
Jeremy Corbyn and other opposition
leaders met to plan their next steps
democracy requires that elected
governments are responsible to
Parliament itself the Prime Minister
seems not to be prepared to do that we
will take every parliamentary action we
can and continue the public campaign to
get no deal taken off the table for all
the gangs at once and then let's have a
general election on Monday a bill
designed to block a no brexit deal
becomes law MPs will then vote on
government plans to trigger an early
election that vote is expected to fail
Boris Johnson is then obliged to write
to the EU asking for an extension if he
can't present an acceptable deal to
Parliament by October 19th but the
government says he will not request that
extension the Prime Minister is still
promising to deliver exit by October
31st he says he has ideas but he has yet
to share them with Parliament or the
media we're dealing with the Prime
Minister here who is going around the
country saying well I may not do what
the law requires now there's only other
way only one other way of squaring that
circle and that would be for the prime
minister to resign with just hours to go
before Parliament shuts down for five
weeks House of Commons Speaker John
Bercow a key figure in the brexit drama
took the opportunity to announce his
resignation
we degrade this Parliament at our peril
this has been the greatest privilege and
honour of my professional life no
applause from the Conservatives who
believe he's been biased against them
but even he cannot distract from the
fact that the Prime Minister has just 40
days to come up with a new brexit deal a
deal that Brussels has yet to see
charlie Angela al-jazeera London
[Applause]